Speaker 1: So, OK, we looked in the last segment
at the cognitive dissonance being experienced
by many former and recent Trump supporters,
because Trump stated the simple fact to Candace
Owens that vaccines work and they are good,
and the people dying of COVID disproportionately
are unvaccinated, all absolutely true.
One of the people triggered by this is conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones.
Now, many of you e-mailed me and said, David,
you've got to cover that.
Alex Jones wife was arrested for domestic
violence over the weekend, and yes, it's hypocritical
that now Alex Jones says this is private.
When he didn't seem to think that the specifics
of what was going on in the families of the
victims of Sandy Hook were private.
I get the hypocrisy.
I don't really care about Alex Jones personal
life.
What I do care about is Alex Jones now completely
turning on Donald Trump.
Alex Jones after this, Candace Owens Donald
Trump interview came in for a so-called emergency
Christmas show in order to sound the alarm,
as he sees it about what Donald Trump said,
suggesting that Donald Trump might be ignorant.
He might be evil.
Or he might be both ignorant.
And evil and saying that Trump lied in his
interview with Candace Owens, so check this
out.
This is really it's the stuff of dreams.
These factions fighting in this way, take
a look.
Speaker 4: This is an emergency Christmas
Day warning to President Trump.
You were either completely ignorant about
the so-called vaccine gene therapy that you
helped ram through with Operation Warp Speed,
or you're one of the most evil men who has
ever lived to push this toxic poison on the
public and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and the
lives of others.
We're about to lay out the basic, incontrovertible
facts that what you told Candace Owens just
a few days ago is nothing but a raft of dirty
lies.
Speaker 1: So Jones goes on to recite endless,
debunked anti-vaccine lies, which I'm not
going to play since I don't want to have to
debunk it piece by piece.
But Jones does mention that the vaccines are
so-called gene therapies.
Now, that's not true.
The vaccines don't change your genes.
They don't stay in your body more than a few
days.
The vaccines are genetically based therapies.
They're based on messenger RNA genetic material.
The vaccines don't enter the cells of the
nucleus, and we could go on.
But Alex Jones is lying, and that probably
doesn't surprise you.
The most interesting part of this is the people
turning on Trump over something so uncontroversial.
Many right wingers will try to soften their
anti-vaccine stances by saying, I'm not against
vaccines, I'm against mandates.
How many times have we heard that?
In his interview, Trump said people should
still have freedom not to take it, but the
vaccines are good and the vaccines work, and
he's still getting crushed.
So all of the people saying we're only against
the mandates, not the vaccines.
In the interview, Trump said, I'm not against.
I'm not for the mandates, I'm just for the
vaccine and they're still going nuts, Trump
said.
The vaccines are good and they work.
And Alex Jones is saying, this is evil and
these are gene therapies.
So were they against the mandates only or
are they actually against the vaccines?
It seems pretty clear, as I've said before,
the more that these people are fighting with
each other, the less they'll be able to put
together functional 2022 campaigns now.
My preference would be that Democrats help
themselves in 2022.
It's unclear whether that's going to happen.
So any help that we can get from the right
I will gladly take.
This also shows us that the idea of big tent
on the right is completely bogus.
If you veer off script for a day, they come
right at you.
And Trump even tells lies in that clip with
Candace Owens lies that typically titillate
his followers.
But just saying, Hey, the vaccines work, it's
mostly unvaccinated people that are dying.
It sent a huge portion of his followers into
a tailspin.
It's hard to imagine this ends well for them,
and that's a good thing.
It's a sort of circular firing squad that
is buying more and more ammunition to use
against each other.
Also, consider how Trump said nutty things
for four years and these people were calm.
He says vaccines work and they go nuts.
Trump said, What if we nuke a hurricane?
He drew with a Sharpie on a hurricane map.
He said, What about injecting bleach?
You know, I could list things.
They're explaining it all the way throughout
Trump's presidency.
Trump says vaccines work and suddenly they
implode.
These are incredible times that we are living
in.
The hope is this damages.
Republicans in 2022 will have these clips
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.
Make sure you're following me at David Pakman
as well.